[Musik]
manchmal erzählen gleichzeitig keiten
schon fast alles es ist der montag
dieser woche vizekanzler habeck fordert
gerade in davos die neuordnung der
weltwirtschaft zur gleichen zeit 200
kilometer entfernt stapft
umweltministerin lemke durch schwinden
muss ein moorgebiet einst ausgetrocknet
durch den torfabbau jetzt soll es hier
wieder richtig morastig werden
intakte moore schlucken co2 in großem
stil und sind heimat seltener tiere und
pflanzen moorschutz hätte das zeug zum
grünen prestige großprojekt
normalerweise doch jetzt schaut die welt
auf völlig anderes und lemke kann nur
leise mahnen die bundesregierung hat
insgesamt klar gestellt dass trotz des
schrecklichen angriffskriegs russlands
gegen die ukraine themen wie der
klimaschutz nicht hinten runter fallen
dürfen diese aufgaben die probleme gehen
ja jetzt nicht einfach weg sie
existieren ja weiter der stellenwert
zeigt sich etwa diese woche in berlin
zum umweltgipfel der g7 haben beide
eingeladen lemke und harbeck die
priorität der weltpresse ist klar
habig gibt das tempo vor er will jetzt
blitzartig flüssiggasterminals bauen
lassen auch für gas aus den usa
teilweise gewonnen mit giftigen methoden
fracking hauptsache schnell weg von
putins stoff doch um welchen preis noch
vor zwei jahren hatte habeck gesprochen
vom ende aller fossilen energien auch
damals schon mit blick auf russland
wir wollen ja nicht statt russischen
grasflächen gas massenweise importieren
sondern nach unser nach unserer
vorstellung gar kein gas wir wollen
keine neuen kapazitäten aufbauen doch
genau das soll jetzt passieren neue
fossile kapazitäten die ersten
sogenannten lng terminals in
wilhelmshaven wie viele werden es am
ende sein wie lange werden die
lieferverträge laufen das fragt sich
auch die grüne basis konkrete antworten
aus berlin fehlanzeige manchen am tisch
wird es da mulmig
im niedersachsen und
das grüne herz blutet ganz klar
ich hoffe dass die politik
einschließlich robert habe ich ihr
versprechen halten das ist wirklich nur
vorübergehend es wie groß ist denn ihr
vertrauen da
soll ich da jetzt ehrlich darauf an
fahrten
nicht so groß aber ich hoffe trotzdem
die hoffnung sap zu lesen ist
noch tiefer geht der riss zu früheren
verbündeten etwa den klima aktiven von
frey dsv future vor dem regieren
demonstrierten grüne auch mal bei ihnen
mit heute pfeift ihr der gegenwind
ja insbesondere die grünen und damit
auch die minister in steffi lemke und
robert habeck schreiben sichert den
kampf gegen die klimakrise den kampf
gegen das artensterben
unfassbar hoch auf die fahne und
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass die politik
die gerade von ihnen betrieben wird
diese probleme weiter verschärfen einige
an der grünen basis mögen auf lemke
hoffen als korrektiv zu hacks
temporausch sie aber macht klar diese
rolle spielt sie nicht jedenfalls nicht
auf der bühne wenn sie auch einmal auf
einen öffentlichen konflikt mit robert
habeck beispielsweise ankommen lassen
wir suchen nach lösungen nicht nach
konflikten
aber manchmal muss man konflikte ja auch
austragen ja das ist richtig
also wenn es sein muss würden sie es tun
wir suchen nach lösungen statt nach
konflikten das ist unser gemeinsames
anliegen
zurück ins allgäuer moore projekt lembke
lässt fördergelder da insgesamt vier
milliarden euro will sie investieren bis
2026 in naturschutz viel geld doch es
kann sie nicht stopfen die wachsende
lücke bei den grünen zwischen 5 um
anspruch und heutigem handeln